yeah there was a story about what's
going on with mortgages in china
they're in uh they're in some
interesting uh
uh uh situation right now by the way i
think they just bought like 300 acres in
south dakota and desantis is not having
it the santa's like sitting saying hey
what are you doing buying all the
farmland in america he said he's calling
a huge problem let me tell you that
concerns me way more than what's
happening when this china banking
situation we covered the story a couple
of years ago with this ever grand i
never even heard of them prior to this
but
you know they've over leveraged and
they've built up crazy amounts of
construction and a lot of chinese
citizens have bought pre-construction
and and you know crazy debt and there's
all this stuff going on in china
i don't really give two shits about
chinese real estate i care about
american real estate okay i care about
if china is buying up u.s farmland and
desantis is calling out
now you're talking to me okay because i
doubt many americans are waking up most
americans are waking up trying to pay
their own [ __ ] rent and their own
mortgage i gotta be worried about what's
going on in china now let me tell you
why don't give two [ __ ] i get it for the
macro economy no no but most americans
are more focused on their real estate
yeah so when desantis calls out what's
going on in china like we talked about
um schools texas a m for example takes
money from confucius institutes so they
can teach chinese doctrine uh
indoctrination to students and take
their money harvard's on this like that
to me is way more of an issue when china
is taking their money and their soft
power and bringing it to united states
whatever happens to china i get it
there's a real estate situation going on
figure it out guys the only reason you
you do
see what's going on with china is the
same way
when you're buying a house you do comps
to see how much houses around your
community are selling for and if you're
a rifle a coffee company you want to
know what your company is worth and you
go to someone that's doing valuation
they're going to do comps to see what
other coffee companies your size are
selling for with the ebitda revenue
market states countries where you're at
it's the same we have to see what's
going on in china's real estate market
and loans because that's a case study to
see what could potentially happen to the
american economy that's the only reason
we would look at what's going on over
there because
it's a scary side they're having a
they're having a rough situation over
there china's home buyers are running
out of patience with the real estate
slump last week a spike in reported
numbers of home buyers halting mortgage
payments prompted many banks to announce
their low exposure to such loans across
banks covered by goldman sachs average
exposure to property including mortgages
was just 17 if more home buyers refused
to pay their mortgages the poor
sentiment would reduce demand and
theoretically prices in a vicious cycle
so these are the reasons why you do pay
attention to some of this stuff but
going back to your point
you're right why are these guys buying
up all this land okay why by the way one
of the places they bought they bought
300 acres of land in north dakota 20
minutes from a military base
what are you doing
like you have to ask a motive yeah
yeah why yeah why are you buying it near
a military base 20 minutes away bill
gates buy up a
crap ton of lounges well he's the
biggest landowner for farmland
by i'm way more okay with bill gates
owning land in the united states than
china the ccp i mean what are we talking
about here when you compare this to the
article that just came out about their
interfering with nuclear weapons and how
they were installing listening devices
the question isn't why are they doing it
the question is why are we allowing it
to happen good why is the government not
stepping in and saying no not a [ __ ]
chance we're gonna live like this is
this is absurd 20 miles from an air base
of course they're going to install
listening devices the question isn't why
it's why is it happening or excuse me
why are we letting it happen i guess the
question would be what is the law
against the country buying land in
another country what is the law
desantis says he wants to make it a
state law in florida so so meaning if
there isn't a law
of doing that well then you need to
create a law years ago when trump was
uncomfortable with huawei's
daughter that was going around talking
to iran and she was in canada i don't
remember if you remember that whole
scandal and huawei was a number two or
number three phone company in the world
what did he say
he said you can't do huawei and us and
while we took a massive hit huawei was
coming up in america huawei took a
massive hit
if if this is what is going on the
president has the ability to sanction
anyone from china buying agriculture or
land in u.s they could do that they can
add those sanctions on chinese investors
that is simply one announcement for him
to make well you hit the nail on the
head chinese investors they're not
coming out and saying hi i'm here on
behalf of the ccp and i'd like to buy
some farmland it's some guy named
whatever or tic toc
yeah that's a whole nother conversation
with white dance china it could be just
a chinese investor there's nothing
illegal about in a guy who's showing up
and buying some property that but you
know that if a guy shows up with a
couple billion bucks from china it's
like
who's really pulling the strings there
right that's the only question
there's nothing illegal about a guy
buying property or corporation buying
property it's just how far removed are
they from the ccp well my assumption is
not far china has no problem you know
saying every day who their enemy is it's
us right for some reason we just can't
say that and i admit it so i think we
just we should assume anything they do
is to harm us if they're coming here to
buy five acres of farmland you know hang
out plant 5g whatever they're out to get
us pat we've been talking about china
for a few years now at least you know on
the podcast right now do you think we
haven't realized what china is about to
do like is there still people in the
government is the citizens are the
citizens of the united states still
unaware of what china is doing i feel
like
it's out there right
it's probably it's out there but a lot
of people are like oh get over it kind
of just like he's not even gonna get
over what you know just turned a blind
eye i think because it's easier to to
not care than it is to care so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]